jacques à yves cochet
non
bon
il coache bonsoir bonsoir alors qu'on
vous arriviez lance de massat me disait
qui sait non mais ces machines est le
tonnerre bonne question
florence yves cochet docteur en
mathématiques
voilà il est né de bien surveiller à
rennes les 946 exacte elle est vraiment
gèle tout de vous il va s'appeler
militant écolo jean est depuis trente
ans fondateur des verts
vous avez été ministre de l'aménagement
du territoire et de l'environnement sous
le gouvernement jospin et aujourd'hui
vous êtes député vert de paris
voilà ouais un set parfait et pas
n'importe quoi
la 18e place
ouais ben apparaît que les yeux comment
tu le trouves yves cochet zoé
j'ai bien si le sport ces techniciens
alors lors de l'université des verts fin
août à grenoble
vous êtes déclaré yves cochet candidat à
la présidentielle 2007
et tout le monde a bien rigolé ainsi que
les concurrents ainsi que ma mère et
boigny vous ai déjà trois chez vous
c'est un parti démocratique et les
verbes on voit ça au ps on voit même sa
l'ump enfin c'est pas anormal qu'il y
ait plusieurs candidatures qui sont
internes y aura des primaires internes
et il dira un ou une comme à l'ump quoi
sceller les militants qui à l'ump non au
tounoi h à 17 il ya une dizaine d'années
maintenant il ya vu deux candidats mais
officielle à la durée chirac
ouais mais là il n'aura de la prochaine
fois aussi un à vous le savez déjà au
lycée tout irait bien
alors vous publiez un bouquin incroyable
non non c'est oui tu vas actuellement
l'école et le tue a moins rigolé quand
tu vas et coûter trop cher
ouais ouais je me barre et alors là
c'est chez fayard ça s'appelle pétrole
apocalypse je fais le pitch
marleix y est le fait d'un futur
la voiture est en panne d'essence un
petit peu une façon de résumer votre
livre mon cher cochet alors vous parlez
d'un triple choc pétrolier déclin de la
production mondiale excède la demande et
tensions au moyen-orient
oui ces trois facteurs vont nous mettre
dans une situation épouvantable c'est à
dire de fin du pétrole bon marché et
surtout la fin du monde tel que nous le
connaissons voilà du bouquin c'est
exactement ça je crois quoi d'ailleurs
on le vit actuellement il ya des
tensions sur les marchés pétroliers qui
fait que à la pompe ou bien pour le
fioul domestique ou pour les marins
pêcheurs dont les gens ont du mal à se
fournir parce que ça coûte de plus en
plus cher ça augmentait de la moitié
depuis l'an dernier donc et ça
continuera
pour les trois facteurs que vous avez
dit dont le premier le plus surprenant
c'est à dire que depuis à peu près 150
ans qu'on utilise le pétrole y compris
évidemment dans les motos et bien on a
l'impression que quand on en veut plus
il en coule plus suivis l'ouvrir le
robinet manque de pot dans quelques
années peut-être même quelques mois ça
va décliner la production mondiale va
décliner si vous appelez le pic de
hubert le pull bear hulbert ça n'est pas
moi bien entendu c'est un géologue
américain qui est décédé maintenant et
qui en 56 donc voila comme assez
longtemps avait prédit qu'en 1970 soit
quatorze ans après la production
intérieure américaine déclinerait alors
à l'époque 11,56 l'américain dean au
marathon hubert tais toi tu comprends
rien c'est pas vrai ils ont attendu 14
ans et ça a décliné et on a maintenant
35 ans de recul et sa déclinaison états
unis depuis 35 ans et maintenant eh bien
c'est pour le monde entier c'est pas
simplement des états unis est donc cette
situation là est tout à fait nouvelle
dans l'histoire de l'humanité motorisés
et voilà faut dire quand même une chose
hein c'est que en fait on une chose
parce que l' agence internationale de
l'énergie
l'institut français du pétrole tous les
économies ces grandes compagnies
pétrolières
ils disent tous le contraire de vous
quand même y discutera du pétrole encore
pendant très longtemps quand même ils le
disent il utilise une sorte de rapport
le rapport arithmétique ne file pas
d'autre chose qui consiste à dire
regardons les réserves qu'on a à peu
près à les mille milliards de barils
vrai mais quand même pas mal et puis
regardons la production et la
consommation annuelle alors à peu près
25 milliards un peu plus par an on
divise l'un par l'autre se fait à peu
près 40 ans
bon bah du pétrole en a encore pour
quarante ans après ce sera peut-être à
sec
c'est idiot il faut pas réfléchir comme
ça ce qui compte c'est pas la dernière
goutte de pétrole dans le dernier avion
militaire américain en 2045 à tout le
monde s'en fout hein
ce qui compte c'est au moment où ça
décline parce que comme tout le monde en
veut plus et qui en aura - il y aura des
tensions est ce qu'on est sûr que ça
décline moi je pense avec avant 2010
donc venus aux mains mais demain matin
c'est dans pas longtemps
demain matin d'autres dit non c'est
plutôt 2015 2020 2050 il ya quand même
démarche de mal je regarde un peu ce que
disent les géologues les plus libres il
ya des géologues officiel chez shell
chez total
bah oui mais ils sont salariés sidi saïd
a man la vérité il vous réduirez et puis
des actions ont baissé et la chambre ont
baissé il n'y a pas un organisme
indépendant qui pourrait me laissa
normalement c'est ce que vous avez dit
c'est à dire celle agence internationale
de l'énergie qui est un organe de l'
ocde enfin un club de pays riches et les
pays riches d'île bas depuis 73 au
moment du premier choc pétrolier en
libye
il faut quand même qu'on sache où on va
on va essayer de faire de la prospective
énergétique dans le domaine pétrolier
malheureusement ils sont sous la coupe
des américains qui ce même des grands
pétroliers george bush est un pétrolier
c'est un an et et pétroliers donc le
lobby est très fort pour dire mais non
ne vous inquiétez pas bonnes gens il y
en a encore pour longtemps et ça sera
pas cher et ben non ça commence à
augmenter et ce qu'on vit actuellement
comme prix du pétrole
aussi bien le baril à new york à la
pompe chez nous du bal le litre 10
balles le litre est une livre en
angleterre donc c est bien tout ça je
pense que ça n'est que le début du
commencement c'est à dire que peut-être
à l'air à l'été 2006 on aura la
nostalgie de l'été 2005 où nous sommes
encore laura brav finalement l'essence
était pas trop cher en 2005 comment on
va faire du stop
en tous les cas c'est la fin du monde
tel que nous le connaissons qui
s'annonce fin du transport aérien de
masse dans une quinzaine d'années on
voit d'ailleurs au enfin il ya quelques
jours et bien deux grandes compagnies
aériennes américaines delta est offert
se sont déclarées en faillite parce que
le prix du kérosène creuset n'est pas
des taxes et n'ont donc y'a pas moyen de
jouer pour les politiques en disant bas
si la substance sur le pétrole augmente
on baisse la taxe et puis finalement à
la pompe c'est pareil dans le kérosène
dès que le prix du baril augmente le
credo de morte deux grandes compagnies
américaines delta et saoudiens qui sont
quand même la numéro 3 numéro quatre aux
états unis en faillite et je pense que
les easy jet et autres ryanair tire tous
ceux qui sont élus corses excédera ils
vont en voir encore plus de mal voit pas
qu'il en existe après 2010 ah oui donc
pour vous le séduite c'est très sérieux
comment ils vont les connais mais je
savais sur les contrôles techniques on
prendra moins l'avion on prendra moins
l'avion l'avion mais c'est ça le monde
qui va changer
olala bon alors explosion du prix des
denrées alimentaires est vite que
finalement toute la chaîne
agroalimentaire est basée sur le pétrole
à commencer par les engrais donc
l'appareil
oui alors on peut expliquer ça d'une
manière simple lorsqu'une famille achète
par exemple un kilo de viande en amont
de ça pour le fabriquer et en effet les
engrais et les phytosanitaires les
pesticides le machinisme agricole les
transports le conditionnement la
réfrigération et finalement la cuisson
c'est 7 litres de pétrole toujours avoir
chez vous dans votre assiette
un kilo de bifteck c était mal assise là
elle l aime pas fait allonger jeunesse
tu veux tu allongée d'accord vous dites
femmes c'est la fin du capitalisme cette
histoire je crois que le monde tel qu'il
est organisé actuellement c'est le
capitalisme qui gagne parce qu'il ya
cette mondialisation des échanges a
beaucoup de comair le des biens des
personnes qui vont partout dans le monde
dans l'impression même quand on est ici
en france que le monde est à notre
portée on loue mon les news magazines on
regarde la télé les plus beaux dans le
métro est partout ben voilà c'est le
voyage aux maldives pour 500 euros par
semaine et c'est pas tout va bien on
peut y aller pense que ça va être plus
difficile parce que ça coûtera
simplement plus cher donc il y aura
moins de personnes quelques riches
peut-être pour y aller mais deux
- on sait bien que le transport aérien
mais le transport aérien
yahia classe affaires à la business
class et puis la classe éco et en été
c'est la classe eco qui paye la route
aérienne pour la classe à peine quand
les échos ne seront plus là eh ben les
compagnies vont dire écoutez on peut
plus supporter la route aérienne et donc
on qu'est ce qu'on fera lors obligés de
prendre des jets privés comment désir
privé ah oui ah ouais vous le ferez
temps où le ferez vous maintenant j'ai
pas les moyens moyens en plus alors en
tous les cas ce que vous dites 6 et le
retour à une société économe local sauf
au bois on remplace les machines par des
outils avec la fin du pétrole bon marché
c'est la fin du pétrole total mais bon
marché il est probable qu'on voit ce
qu'on appelle la décroissance de
décroissance de l'économie décroissance
du commerce et donc ça on sait pas faire
on n'a pas d' imaginaire collectif
et puis les économistes ne savent pas
vers les politiques pas plus pour se
voir comment on peut vivre en amont en
décroissance crois que c'est ce qui va
d'abord des trois c'est justement le
tourisme avec la france
le premier site touristique du monde il
ya 75 millions d'étrangers qui viennent
dans notre beau pays sans papiers
souvent mais cela ils repartent pas
alors que d'autres partent chez eux
eh bien je crois que si simplement il
rêvait 50 millions en 2010 ça veut dire
un tiers a disparu ou bien maligne et le
nombre de bistrot d'hôtels de
restaurants qui serait simplement au
chômage ouais et donc donc c'est un
problème on est à part ça c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle quand même de savoir
qu'un jour il aura plus d'essence qu'il
faudra trouver des énergies
renouvelables qu'on peut lui ramoin
parce qu on voyagera - l'avion pelé
énormément quand il oui mais vous devez
raison mais vous êtes l'écolo de oui
mais je trouve pas je veux m'inscrire
parce que je trouve pas de leaders qui
charismatique voilà je trouve que les
verts ils passent leur temps à
s'engueuler oh ben non non non non mais
je vais y aller je représente et je vais
mettre un peu de l'ailé vers
s'engueulent ça c'est vous regardez à
l'ump est ce que c'est quand même
l'amour fraternel qui a débouclé je ne
parle pas du parti socialiste les verts
il parle peu politique beaucoup de
politiques et pas beaucoup d'écologistes
qui sont trop accaparés
on en fait de l'écologie de terrain donc
on va se retrouver dans une société
finalement agraire société sans doute
avec des implantations humaines moins
massive par exemple que l'ile-de-france
pas toutes ces grandes conurbations où
on a du mal à se déplacer enfin je ne
sais pas où vous habitez les uns les
autres neuilly non car il est plus
facile mais il verrait pas encore les
embouteillages qui a tous les matins pas
simplement en région parisienne mais à
rotterdam amsterdam autour de londres à
marseille à lyon à bordeaux et c'est bon
c'est pas agréable donc conjoint d'une
certaine façon c'est une divine surprise
finalement ce qui se passe si on prend
des mesures qui sont à la fois
démocratiquement débattu et en même
temps hélas un peu rigoureuse on peut
s'en sortir sans trop mettre en disons
en danger la paix la côte est comme ça
il n'y a plus de yayi il ya plus de
machines ya des outils on se chauffe au
bois en cuisine au bois pour un
écologiste c'est le bonheur ça c'est ce
que vous voulez non mais vous voulez me
faire passer pour une sorte de ne blâmer
tennis et bien non non non ça je me pète
et ninon même souffert du tout même vont
nous faire plaisir à auxi mots et non
mais là il s'agit pas de se faire
plaisir
il s'agit de regarder la réalité en face
et elle elle peut parfois être les
agréable parfois évidemment elle est
très agréable quand je regarde par
exemple les deux voisines
alice est bonne elle est belle quand je
regarde en face encore link est malade
pendant y'en a une qui est mal à bing et
passera pas l'antenne non il ya un truc
est quand même très inquiétant dans
votre lit tu sais que vous dites ou s'il
sauve rage immédiat voulu ou c'est la
guerre et comme moi je pense que ça sera
pas le sevrage immédiat et voulu parce
que les gens voudront jamais rouler à 90
se chauffer au bois etc etc
il va y avoir une espèce de guerre
énorme pour s'emparer du pétrole c'est
ce qui s'est déjà passé en irak
exactement si les américains sont allés
en irak et bien entendu enfin en objet
ce que vous nous racontez soit ceux qui
a la solution soft qui va jamais marcher
et que la solution hard celle elle va
vraiment arriver et les irakiens et est
là c'est pour leur grand malheur le
vivent
quotidiennement et en 2003 avant abou
chadi
je veux aller en irak parce que saddam
est un dictateur il a des armes de
destruction massive alors les dictatures
là on est en train de fêter le 60e
anniversaire de l'onu la moitié des pays
de l'onu sur les dictatures 1 et
pourquoi dès lors celle ci plutôt qu'une
autre effet après les armes de
destruction massive c'est le mensonge du
monde a menti non c'est parce que là il
ya du pétrole beaucoup de pétrole et en
plus il est facile à extraire ça coûte
pas très cher et bas plutôt que d'aller
je ne sais pas en alaska ou ailleurs où
là c'est plus difficile
donc c'est pour ça qu'il y va on va il
va y avoir la guerre et il ya déjà la
guerre mais ça va ça va ça va devenir
énorme je ne souhaite le patron souhaite
mais c'est évident en vie et bien que
moins il y aura de pétrole plus sûr à de
guerre pour avoir du pétrole parce
qu'encore une fois les gens vont pas
accepter de se sevrer volontairement je
ne suis pas super je ne suis pas ce nom
mais personne est un saint les verts
sont pas génétiquement différents des
autres un peu permise quand même ah non
moi je ne suis pas un ogm jamais après
après l'irak ce sera la zee centre avec
ses bars à la casse kanye aimerait
l'asie mineure sont les géopolitique
non il ya de fortes chances quand même
que la solution guerrière préval vous
êtes d'accord
il ya une connexion l'a déjà arrêts le
problème est de contenir et même
évidemment de cesser ces guerres est
d'essayer de rentrer alors quand je dis
sobriété ça va pas dire ça va être
triste
ah la la qu'est-ce qu'on va s'ennuyer ya
moyen d'être joyeux d'être vivant avec
des bougies à vélo non mais comme on dit
dans mes amis d'aller quoi 106,10 moins
de biens plus de liens mais c'est pas
mal
moi je préfère en effet l'amour l'art et
la poésie plutôt que simplement rouler à
180 sur le trou ce qui est interdit